(suspenseful music)
- I don't know,
we don't spend a whole
bunch of time holding hands.
- Stop makin' excuses.
("Echoes of Tension" by
Warner/Chappell Production Music)
- Okay, got it.
It's already the hardest part.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to wait to compare,
but I feel like this
hand might be too small.
Um, this is so nerve-racking!
Oh, this is so hard.
Now, I'm like Goldilocks.
I feel like this hand might
be a little too big. (laughs)
Could be, could be Matt?
This hand is definitely
colder than the other hands.
That's my first observation,
so that makes me feel
like it could not be him,
but I don't know.
The size feels right on this one.
It's equally as soft as the other,
everyone's had really soft hands today.
Yeah, okay, I think I'm ready to guess.
I think Matt is hand number three.
(laughs)
- You got it! (laughs)
- Yay!
- Well done, babe.
(both laughing)
I was nervous there for a second.
- I thought I was a horrible boyfriend.
- It would have been okay
if he had gotten it wrong.
- I would have made dinner
or something, I think.
- Yeah!
- When I felt hand three, I knew.
- I don't know if I could have done it.
I mean, his fingers kind
of give it away, but...
- My spindly alien fingers?
- [Matt] (laughing) Yeah!
Your alien face fingers.